You know that feeling, right?
That deep, just bone weary
exhaustion.
It goes way beyond just a long
day.
It's that kind of tired you get
from like constantly doing this
moral math in your head, trying
to balance what you give versus
what you see and feeling like
the whole system is just well,
rigged somehow.
That weariness of carrying this
weight and feeling squeezed for
it.
So what if there's a specific
kind of maybe societal weariness
driving some of the biggest
talks and political shifts in
America right now?
Well, that feeling you're
describing, that secific
tiredness, it actually has a
name, poverty fatigue.
OK.
And it's really crucial to get
what it isn't.
It's not about the suffering of
poor people themselves.
That's real, Absolutely.
But it's separate, right?
This is more about the exertion
felt by people living, you know,
shoulder to shoulder with
poverty, people feeling like
they're constantly funding
systems that just don't seem
effective, and really
importantly, feeling like
they're the ones left holding
the bag for it all.
So today we're doing a deep dive
looking into Chris Abraham's
piece, Poverty, Fatigue, and
Trump's big beautiful bill.
A nation caught between the net
and the pavement.
Yeah, it's a really insightful
article.
It gives this really thought
provoking look at this powerful
but often kind of unspoken
dynamic.
Exactly.
And our mission today is to,
well, unpack the subtle but
really influential type of
exhaustion, right?
The one that's shaping how
people see things, their
perceptions, maybe even how they
vote across the country.
We want to give you a clear path
to understanding this complex,
sometimes uncomfortable idea.
OK, let's unpack that feeling
then.
Abraham's article talks about
poverty fatigue as this deep,
quiet resentment, something you
might not say out loud, but you
absolutely feel it.
Like in your gut.
Think about it, right?
Your own paycheck feels like
it's shrinking.
Your bus stop still looks, I
don't know, neglected, right.
And then maybe you see someone
with a brand new phone paid for
by some benefit you didn't even
know about.
Or the classic story you hear
passed around.
Yeah, the single parents
supposedly bragging about eating
lobster using their EBT card,
their food stamp card, while
your own kids are having like,
spaghetti and maybe a cheap hot
dog for dinner.
Right, and the article makes the
point you can't prove every
single one of those stories.
No, but as it says, you feel
them in your bones.
That feeling is potent.
Exactly.
The defines it as the psychic
exhaustion from carrying a
system that feels rigged.
Yes, and like you touched on,
it's so, so important to repeat
this is not about the suffering
of people in poverty.
This is about the exhaustion of
feeling like you're the quote
sucker holding the bag, as the
article says, while politicians
are maybe praising their own
moral goodness all on your dime.
It's a weariness that's more
about perceived unfairness,
feeling taken advantage of
maybe.
Yeah, rather than your own
personal hardship.
Precisely.
So this isn't exactly new, is
it?
Abraham's Peace traces the
history of this poverty fatigue
back back to the 80s, right?
Mentions Reagan and the Cadillac
Queen story.
That's right, Linda Taylor.
She was a real person in Chicago
involved in fraud, yes, but
Reagan transformed her story
into this powerful symbol
nationwide.
A myth, almost.
Pretty much.
And it really resonated with
working people for generations.
It just perfectly captured that
gut feeling.
I'm scraping by.
She's scheming.
That sense of unfairness.
Keep unfairness, frustration.
Exactly.
And it wasn't just her.
We still hear versions of the
lobster on food stamps thing,
right?
Echoes from the 80s and 90s.
Oh yeah, the article notes.
Were these stories statistically
huge?
No, but they were sticky.
And what's really fascinating is
why they stick so powerfully.
Abraham suggests that quote.
Fairness in America is primal,
moralistic, petty.
The core feeling fueling these
stories wasn't just about, you
know, charity or lack of it.
It was about justice or
perceived injustice.
We can forgive suffering, he
writes.
But we hate seeing someone
unworthy appear to do better
than us while we scrape by.
That primal sense of
indignation.
That's the engine that makes
them so sticky.
OK, here's where it gets really
interesting for me.
The article uses this vivid
analogy contrasting safety Nets
Europe versus America.
Yeah, it's a powerful image.
It describes Europe's safety net
as a hammock.
It catches you before you hit
the ground hard.
OK, like in Germany.
Lose your job.
You can keep getting your
salary, maybe on a sliding
scale.
Housing, healthcare, education.
They're described as a rope that
holds you up, not just barely
alive.
So a much higher net.
A much higher, more
comprehensive cushion designed
to prevent those deep falls.
Now contrast that with America's
CST Net, the article calls it.
What a fishing line 6 inches off
the ground.
Exactly a very different image
the American approach as
presented as kind of like fall,
crack your teeth, then maybe get
a little bit of help.
And we justify that culturally
with ideas of freedom, personal
responsibility.
Right, that's the narrative.
But then COVID hit and suddenly
you had stimulus checks,
enhanced unemployment, and for a
lot of people in America, it was
this brief, unexpected glimpse
of what a hammock actually feels
like.
So actually experiencing that
even briefly changed the game,
changed how they saw things.
The article argues it did.
It wasn't just theory anymore,
it was a taste of something
different, something that maybe
challenged those long held
narratives about purely
individual responsibility.
Exactly.
What's fascinating, the article
suggests, is how tasting Kat
Hammock suddenly made people
realize, oh, this is what a
higher, more supportive net
feels like, right?
Those abstract conversations
about freedom suddenly had this
very real, lived counterpoint.
It became tangible.
Which brings us right into how
this fatigue shows up in
politics.
The article mentions Zohron
Mandani, the democratic
socialist who won that primary
in NYC.
Right.
Mandani's win, according to
Abraham, kind of made the code
visible for a lot of people.
What does that mean the code?
It means democracy itself is now
being explicitly framed as the
the variable for democratic
socialism.
OK, So in real terms, that
translates to a political vision
of higher taxes, a thicker net,
more universal entitlements.
It's out there, clearly stated,
and the right sees this shift
clearly.
Oh.
Absolutely.
That's why, the article argues,
you hear that constant chant.
America is a Republic, not a
democracy.
Yeah, you hear that, A.
Lot and the piece says this
isn't just, you know, arguing
semantics about government
types.
It's described as panic.
The panic.
Panic from people who see the
hammock is creeping upward.
They see this fundamental shift
and they fear what it means for
the economy, for social
structures.
Maybe concerns about wealth
redistribution?
Individual liberties.
Exactly.
That a pure democracy might
override those things.
That's the fear being tapped
into and.
Then you have millions in that
exhausted middle, right?
The ones who think, hey, that
hammock's not for me.
I'll never benefit for them.
This creeping hammock is in
progress.
The article says they see it as
more dead weight strapped to
their back.
Just another burden they, the
taxpayers, have to carry.
Yeah, which leads to this really
crucial point the article makes,
how this moral fatigue can,
well, shapeshift.
It's not static.
No, it's very adaptable and it
can mutate in some pretty
dangerous ways.
The piece gives some really
striking examples, like black
fatigue.
Right, which started as this
term for the very real deep
exhaustion black people feel
dealing with systemic racism.
But now you jump on TikTok and
you see that same phrase,
twisted, weaponized.
I'm tired of black people acting
up.
Wow, so it flips from solidarity
to resentment.
Exactly.
And similarly, white fatigue, a
term scholars like Joseph Flynn
used for the weariness white
people feel facing racism's
complexities right now, that
gets turned into a punchline.
Oh, I'm tired of white people
being tired.
It highlights this dangerous
path the article identifies.
Fatigue is contagious.
It becomes blame.
Blame becomes politics.
That's the critical
transformation and.
That's what drives people away
from maybe traditional political
thinking or alliances.
And this is exactly what makes
people, as the article puts it,
check out of Solidarity.
Yes, they check out of broader
social movements and instead
might align with anyone who just
validates their own feelings.
Someone who tells them you're
not crazy, you're right to be
tired.
That validation becomes
incredibly powerful.
So with all this frustration and
fatigue swirling around, where
does someone like Donald Trump
fit in?
The article looks at his big,
beautiful bill.
Right.
Abraham details that bill as
having these concrete pieces.
Massive tax cuts for the rich,
yes, but also significantly, no
taxes on tips or overtime for
the working class.
OK, tangible things.
Very tangible.
And while the article definitely
notes the criticisms, you know
it's partly a scam.
It blows up the deficit.
It stresses, it's powerful,
maybe emotional appeal.
It says quote.
It does one thing the left
refuses to do.
It says we see you.
And that's why the working class
response.
The argument is yes, they don't
care about the rich man's
windfall, OK.
What they do care about are
those few crumbs they get to
keep for themselves.
Because they don't believe
they'll ever get that European
hammock.
Exactly.
They don't trust those big
abstract promises of a future
perfect system.
So they trust what's in their
pocket now more than the promise
of a better system tomorrow.
It's that immediate pragmatic
satisfaction winning out, yeah.
This raises a really important
question, doesn't it?
Especially about the Democratic
Party strategy, Maybe.
Well, Abraham argues that the
modern left has sort of become a
temple that worships the lepers,
meaning, meaning the focus is
intensely on the most
marginalized, the truly
destitute, the morally symbolic.
OK.
And while that focus absolutely
aligns with, you know,
compassion, maybe the Kingdom of
heaven, as the article puts it,
it quickly adds the Kingdom of
Washington is not the Kingdom of
Heaven.
Implying that idealism doesn't
always translate well into
practical governance for
everyone.
Or that in focusing so intently
on the symbolic bottom rung, the
practical burdens on the working
middle get overlooked.
Yeah, which reinforces that
contrast with Europe again.
Right.
In Germany the idea is the
hammock covers everyone from the
middle class down.
But in America?
In America, the article claims
the moral Halo only covers the
bottom.
So if you're the plumber, the
truck driver, the lion cook,
yeah, you're just the taxpayer.
Pretty much the feeling is no
one sees you as needing special
consideration and if you
complain about the load.
You get told to check your
privilege.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Which you can imagine creates
this deep sense of alienation
for a lot of people.
And this, the article argues, is
what leads many in that working
middle to quote Drift to Trump,
the roughnecks ruffian, the only
guy who tosses them a bone,
while the left offers sermons
and hashtags.
It's about feeling acknowledged,
even if it's just a small
gesture.
Which brings us to what the
article calls the ugly secret.
Poverty fatigue votes.
Simple as that.
Yeah.
So just to recap that cycle
Abraham lays out, fatigue turns
into resentment, and that
resentment turns directly into
votes.
And because of that powerful
cycle, the working class keeps
slipping away from maybe more
traditional political homes.
Why?
Because, as the article sums it
up, they'd rather be tossed a
cheap break now than be told how
good they'll have it someday
when the perfect system finally
arrives.
The immediate, tangible thing
wins.
It often does, yeah.
Over the long term from abstract
promise.
So how do you even start to fix
that?
What does the article suggest?
It suggests you have to get
honest about the grift, the
moral hazard, the Cadillac
Queens and the lobster EBT
myths.
Face it ahead, I acknowledge it
all.
Some are true, some aren't, but
the resentment is always real.
You have to deal with the.
Feeling and that moral hazard
part.
That's the idea that safety Nets
might discourage work for some.
Right.
It's that perception, whether
statistically accurate or not
across the board, that safety
Nets can sometimes reduce the
incentive for self-reliance.
It feeds into the fatigue.
So the stark conclusion is just
laid bare.
Poverty fatigue is real.
It votes.
Guess why?
It's this powerful, often
invisible force just shaping
everything absolutely.
So bringing it back to that core
metaphor one last time, Europe
offers a hammock, America a
fishing line just above the
concrete.
And then Trump comes along,
tosses you a bone and,
crucially, says, I see you.
And understanding that dynamic,
that poverty fatigue, is just
profoundly important if you want
to grasp what's happening in
society and politics today.
It's a really key factor often
missed in why people vote the
way they do, even when it seems
maybe counterintuitive from the
outside.
So something to think about,
right?
How much of our public
arguments, our political
divides, might actually be
rooted in this unspoken
exhaustion?
Moral, emotional, financial What
kind of new conversations could
we even start?
What solutions might appear if
we really tried to see this
fatigue in ourselves and in
others, instead of just
dismissing it or making it
political ammo?